hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video and it's that time again where we
go over the rewards for the season
winners of the faction war and for honor
real quick though in about an hour or
two of this video going live I'm gonna
be streaming some foreigner like I
usually do every Saturday so come by say
hello and chill out with everybody and
have a good time I'd love to see you all
there if you do show up but that out of
the way make sure you like the video if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
cover the leaks news patch notes and
tips and guides for for honor and with
that let's get into these rewards so
this current season is season 5 and we
got some decent rewards this time as
opposed to last season but if you're
unaware the Vikings almost sweep the
entire faction world with five wins but
samurai came out on top during this
round and managed to get a win I've been
hearing on Reddit that it was because
that they added an extra 24 hours to the
round or whatever happened to be but
regardless the samurai got one win in
the Vikings got four which leaves the
Vikings in first place samurai in second
place and the Knights in last place now
that that is taken care of let's get
into what these actual rewards are so
first up is the outline it isn't too bad
season 3 still has one of the best
outlines in the game and luckily that's
when the Knights won but this is a close
second if you're new and don't know how
this stuff works everyone in the game
gets an outline for participating of
course since you're part of a faction
but the winners of the faction war get
the ornaments we're gonna be showing
later in the video but as well for the
outline everyone gets the same outline
except the winners get a gold color
second place gets a silver color and the
last place gets bronze if you don't know
what place you're in like I said before
the Vikings are in first samurai are in
second and Knights are in third because
of how many wins they got in the
different rounds of the faction war this
season in terms of the design it's not
really that bad it does have the wolf at
the top because of the age of wolves
that was the name of the season and a
little quick nod to apollyon since
majority of the season was based off of
her she liked to call to people she
didn't like sheep or people that awaited
their death so that's why there's a
sheep at the bottom so a little quick
nod to her other than that the design is
pretty damn good
next up is the ornaments and honestly
they're really not that bad either
last season if you remember we got those
green coins I believe and they honestly
were pretty terrible not many people
liked them but now we have factions
specific ornaments and that's a big plus
for us credit to Ken's a radical on
reddit for the images if you want to see
the photo for yourself and all that [ __ ]
together you can go in the description
I'll have a link for it so shout out to
Ken's a radical like I said for the
images on reddit but the name is going
to be called hunters boon and the
Knights ornament is decent-looking got
this decent looking swirls in the middle
as a
small design personally to me though I
wouldn't really use this but it's cool
nonetheless if you don't have an
ornament for your knight character the
Viking ornament and personally to me has
to be one of the best of the three that
with that the Vikings are going to
beginning for the faction war winners I
just like the red tips on the edge of
the feathers and I'm assuming they're
going to be changing based off of the
color that you equip on your character
and there's also the middle centerpiece
with some small detailed designs that
really make the ornament look nice and
then lastly is the samurai ornament in
this ornament just like the previous one
is also really nice-looking
it's got curved horns and it looks like
on the side that has some flower designs
and some patterns on the inside of the
horns kind of like little engravings and
also has a skeleton and what looks like
a gem or two in the center to really
make the ornament look really badass and
cool just in case you knew and don't
know how the ornaments work either as
opposed to the outlines for the faction
war winner you get all the ornaments
that I just talked about even though it
has it for the Knights and the samurai
the Vikings if you were part of the
Viking faction you get it for all the
characters if it was if you were had to
be viking faction and then you only got
it for viking characters that wouldn't
make sense and that would be basically
cutting off half of the faction teams
and all that stuff so basically if you
win the faction where you get the
ornaments for all the people as opposed
to me and the samurai where we didn't
get any of this since I am a knight I
didn't get any of the ornaments sadly
but yeah hopefully that cleared a little
bit of things up so just to reiterate
the outline is everybody gets it but
it's a different color based on your
place and it for the ornament only the
winners will get it and they get it for
every character in the game
tell me Waterman you guys like the most
in the comments below I'd love to know
your thoughts and that's basically it
though I'm assuming there's also some
emblems to put on your characters armor
I didn't receive any like I said since
I'm in last place which sucks but not
many people really use the emblems
anyway I couldn't even find any images
on reddit so maybe they didn't even have
emblem didn't even have the emblems or
maybe they did I'm not entirely sure so
I do apologize if there was and I didn't
show them but that's gonna be the end of
the video today guys hope you guys did
enjoy it like I said I'm going to be
streaming in about an hour or two of
this video going up so definitely come
by say hello show with everyone have fun
time really loved if you came by like
the video if you did enjoy really does
help me out subscribe if you're new I
cover the leaks the news the patch notes
tips and guides for foreign or all that
good stuff the informational site of for
honor I like the cover my two most
recent videos are gonna be on screen as
well if you guys do want to check that
out highly recommend you do but that
guys hoping for various turday peace out
and enjoy those rewards